The Simpsons has entertained families
for over 27 years with silly jokes and
profound ironic truths but did you know
they also had a knack for predicting the
future stick around for the ultimate
prediction that involved the entire
universe if you're new here subscribe to
the things Channel so you are the first
to see our new videos and click on the
like button if you enjoyed this one now
check out 20 times the Simpsons
predicted the future
Lady Gaga Lady Gaga appeared on The
Simpsons to perform a show that blew
everyone's minds in Springfield in the
performance she flew above the crowd on
wires while fire and sparks shut out of
her metallic bra
five years later Gaga jumped off the top
of the stadium attached to wires to fly
over the Houston crowd for the Superbowl
halftime show now since Lady Gaga was
the actual voice of her own character in
the Simpsons episode odds are she may
have been unknowingly influenced by this
cartoon concert could this have informed
her decision to fly over the Houston
crowd five years later you'd be the
judge
all-you-can-eat we all know Homer
Simpson as the beer-drinking food-loving
Oh fish family man who makes foolish
decisions but always seems to land on
his feet we credit that to his
supportive family but did you guys see
the episode where he sued the
all-you-can-eat restaurant for turning
him away before he was full seems too
ridiculous to happen in real life right
guess again
20 years later a ticked-off customer at
an all-you-can-eat fish fry restaurant
spearheaded a one-man protest because
the restaurant turned him away after he
ate over a dozen fish the guy said he
was still hungry and the restaurant was
guilty for false advertising the
Siegfried and Roy tiger attack it's only
natural to think that the wild jungle
cats would probably eject to being
captive entertainers for a bunch of
drunk gamblers in Las Vegas in 1993 ten
years before the actual Tiger attack The
Simpsons did an episode showing a white
tiger riding a unicycle wearing a
spinning hat and smoking a pipe for the
Siegfried and Roy show the tiger fondly
remembers his life in the jungle before
they shot him with a tranquilizer gun
and brought him to the stage then he
attacks his captors while the real-life
incident was unfortunate many of us did
see that coming we hope you have
recovered Roy three
fish do you remember the Simpsons
episode where Bart caught a three-eyed
fish in the ponds near the nuclear power
plants that's too crazy to actually
happen right get ready to be totally
creeped out say hello to this real
three-eyed wolfish from Argentina who
grew up in a reservoir fed by a nuclear
power plant what's really uncanny is the
plant owner was running for political
office just like mr. burns in the
Simpsons episode in the show
Marge cooks the fish and serves it to
mr. burns who spits it out effectively
ruining his political chances though
nobody is planning to cook and serve
this real live fish they plan to embalm
it for Prosperity Ebola outbreak did you
know that the Simpsons predicted the
outbreak of Ebola virus 17 years before
it actually happened in the episode Bart
is sick in March tells him to read
Curious George and the Ebola virus this
episode came out in the 90s before any
major outbreak of the virus in 2014
nearly 19,000 340 cases of Ebola were
reported in eight countries the virus
killed 7,000 518 people making it one of
the most deadly outbreaks in history
showing a contagious monkey on a book
probably made for a funny joke back then
but people probably wouldn't be laughing
at that today how did the Simpsons
predict that one that's a mock Oh plans
in this episode Homer takes the family
to stay on his grandpa's old farm where
he is there Homer succeeds in growing
the world's first tomato tobacco hybrid
plant and calls it the tobacco plant
Bart eats these tobacco's and gets
hopelessly addicted to them and home
returns done an offer from a cigarette
company to buy the plant this inspired a
hardcore Simpsons fan by the name of Rob
Bauer to create his own tobacco plant
and he actually succeeded the creators
of the show were so impressed they
invited Bauer and his family to their
offices where they tried the plant
themselves faulty voting machines
remember in 2012 when that voting
machine in Pennsylvania had to be
removed because it was switching votes
for Obama in two votes for Romney well
The Simpsons predicted that too in the
beginning of the episode Homer tries to
vote for Obama on an electric voting
machine every time he hits the button
for Obama it counts it as a vote for
McCain when Homer figures out the
machine is rigged the machine sucks him
up and tries to eat him that episode
came out in two
thousand and eight four years before
this happened in real life well aside
from the machine eating people part many
people had this fear about electronic
voting machines the first autocorrects
failed in 1994 there was a fancy device
called the Newton that was supposed to
be cutting edge technology it is a
distant ancestor of the iPhone in the
episode the school bullies fried a memo
into the device to remind them to beat
up Martin
but the device auto corrects it to eat
up Martha apparently the device had
pretty poor handwriting recognition the
former director of engineering for the
iOS apps at Apple said this episode
served as an inspiration for them to get
the iPhone keyboard right way to go
simpsons smartwatches speaking of
technology did you know the Simpsons
also predicted the invention of
smartwatches in 1995 they aired the
futuristic episode called Lisa's wedding
in which Lisa's fiance makes a phone
call with his watch this is 20 years
before the invention of the Apple watch
maybe the writers of the show should get
some patents pending they could be super
rich by now if you want to find out
about future trends and technology look
no further than this seemingly innocent
cartoon what we want to know is will the
alien invasion come true to 3d printer
in a 2005 episode titled future drama
Marge Simpson takes a picture of Bart
and Lisa the night of their senior prom
when she takes the picture with what
looks like a normal Polaroid camera the
photo quickly transforms into a 3d cake
with Bart and Lisa's picture on it it
wouldn't be until nine years later that
the tech world introduced 3d printers
say hello to the foodini
it's capable of printing pasta burgers
and chocolate the printer uses edible
ingredients that are stored in stainless
steel capsules we are wondering just how
good this printed food tastes Trump
presidency the majority of Americans
were dumbfounded when Donald Trump was
elected as the 45th President of the
United States but if they watch The
Simpsons they could have expected it in
an episode titled Bart - the future Lisa
place Trump's successor saying they
inherited a large budget crunch from
President Trump in the episode
an Indian casino manager tells Bart when
his feature will look like in 30 years
he predicts that Lisa will be America's
first straight female president and Bart
will have a ponytail and here we are 18
years later and President Trump is an
office
maybe the creators should be betting on
future events at the casino the god
particle in the 1998 episode where Homer
tries to become an inventor a physicist
noticed something pretty remarkable on
the chalkboard Homer is using physicist
and author dr. Simon Singh shared that
he saw the solution for Higgs boxin also
known as the god particle mass on
Homer's blackboard the Higgs boson is an
elementary particle that helps explain
the mass of other particles in the
universe it was officially confirmed in
2012 14 years after Homer scratched out
the equation on the chalkboard way to go
Homer they call it the god particle
because the Higgs was a concept of
biblical proportions
oh and Homer also invented an electric
hammer The Shard there's another
remarkable prediction in the Lisa's
wedding episode in the episode Lisa
takes a trip to London next to the
digital Big Ben clock tower you can see
a skyscraper behind the Tower Bridge
that looks crazy similar to a future
building called the shard the shard
wasn't erected until 2009 in the exact
same location 14 years after this
episode aired the building wasn't
complete until 2012 how do they know
that seriously our minds are blown The
Simpsons even predicted a year span in
which the building would be built in the
episode a fortune teller shows Lisa what
her wedding would be like in the year
2010 just two years after the building
was finished robot librarians
here's another prediction from Lisa's
wedding episode the creator's revealed
the existence of robot librarians who
had replaced human librarians this is
super eerie because over 20 years later
these robotic students from the
University of Aberystwyth invented a
prototype for a walking library robot
scientists in Singapore are also testing
their own robot librarians we wonder if
they will be able to shush loud students
the same way miss Thermopolis did in our
school library do these robots come with
stern expressions and waggling fingers
the Simpsons predicted it first are they
geniuses or what robots are the wave of
the future lunch lady Doris the Simpsons
had a lot of fun joking about all the
gross things that could be in school
lunches but who knew their predictions
would actually become fact take the
horse meat scandal for example in 1994
lunch lady Doris was digging into a
barrel of assorted horse parts to feed
the school children we were sure that
was too gross to become a reality
boy were we wrong nine years later the
Food Safety Authority of Ireland found
horse DNA in beef burger samples in
supermarkets don't worry they arrested
the men responsible for the scandal
lunch lady Doris will have to get her
lunch meat somewhere else
Disney buys 20th Century Fox in the 1998
episode when you dish upon a star Homer
pitches a script which is produced by
Brian Grazer and Ron Howard it's being
produced at the studio at 20th Century
Fox but if you look closely at the sign
it says a division of Walt Disney
Company 20 years later in December of
2017 Disney bought 20th Century Fox for
a cool fifty two point four billion
dollars with the purchase that gained
control of the x-men avatar and you
guessed it the Simpsons but how did they
know 20 years ago that this would happen
we're starting to believe they have a
time machine hidden somewhere the u.s.
beats Sweden in curling at the Olympics
The Simpsons can even predict the
outcome of the Olympic Games in 2010
episode called Boy Meets curl where
Marge and Homer compete in curling at
the Vancouver Olympics and they beat
Sweden in real life the US men's Olympic
curling team came out of nowhere and
crushed Sweden even though they were
behind that's exactly the way it played
out for Marge and Homer this Simpsons
episode aired eight years before this
incredible u.s. victory in the 2018
Winter Olympics
maybe the writers are psychic seriously
this is beyond coincidence how could
anybody have predicted an Olympic
curling victory Michelangelo's David
censorship in the episode titled itchy
and scratchy and Marge the town spoke in
Springfield protested against
Michelangelo's Statue of David opposing
its appearance in a look
museum they called the statue obscene
because of its nudity this episode aired
in 1990 26 years prior to a censorship
headline in Russia
apparently in July 2016 russia
campaigners were voting to close a copy
of Michelangelo's David statue that had
been erected in central st. Petersburg a
local woman launched a complaint saying
the plastic replica was an eyesore and a
bad influence on students at a nearby
school they called the campaign to put
clothes on the statues private parts the
dressed David Initiative letter from the
Beatles in 1991 the Simpsons showed
Ringo Starr from the immensely famous
band The Beatles answering fan mail that
had been written several decades prior
in September of 2013 to Essex based fans
got a letter from Paul McCartney in
response to fan mail they sent the band
50 years before the fan sent a recording
to the band - the package was sent to a
London theater where the band was going
to play but was lost
it wasn't recovered until years later a
BBC show called the One Show gave the
fans their letter back on TV they also
gave the fans the reply from McCartney
on the show the doughnut-shaped galaxy
in 1999 in an episode titled the saved
Lisa's brain the famous physicist and
cosmetologist Stephen Hawking is hanging
out at Moe's with Homer Stephen says
something pretty interesting he tells
Homer that his theory of a
doughnut-shaped universe is intriguing
and that he may have to steal it and
then he punches homer in the face with
an electric boxing glove don't what four
years after homers yummy Theory was
discussed on the show scientists
discovered radiation patterns that
suggested the universe is a round tube
shaped with a hollow centre they call it
a torus shape cosmology never looked so
delicious and that's 20 times the
Simpsons predicted the future thanks for
watching we'll see you next time on the
things
[Music]